cross-site scripting is the number one
vulnerability on the web today um if you
are writing any kind of web software and
you don't know about this uh you should
know this um and if you are the kind of
person who likes to play about with
websites and break them in a definitely
legal manner uh you should know this to
explain it we have to go back to the
early days of the Internet we have to go
back to Tim berners-lee sitting at CERN
making up how the web will work the web
is based on something called HTML
hypertext markup language um most people
who are watching this I think will know
how this works
um but just very quickly it means that
you have tags an HTML document starts
with angle brackets like this and closes
with angle brackets like this anything
between angle brackets is read as an
instruction so if I want to put some
text in bold I put a B tag and a closed
B tag and I put some text in the middle
and that becomes bold
this is why I know you've been getting
comments about this the ending graphic
on computer file should have a little
slash like this one here to make it over
otherwise you're kind of saying that
you're starting a new one no doubt all
sorts of pedantic people have been
emailing you about that those angle
brackets wherever they are in the
document mean an instruction is coming
here so what do you do if you want to
put an angle by which basically a less
than sign into your document while you
do something called escaping instead of
sending the angle bracket you send an
ampersand and then LT for less than and
then a semicolon and that means when the
user actually reads it it will become an
angle bracket great wonderful and that
works fine it means in the old days the
world wide web you could send a request
and the document would come back and the
angle brackets would not mess everything
then we'll move on a bit and and we
start coming back with more interactive
things someone comes along and invents
JavaScript and JavaScript is is a
programming language that sits in the
middle of webpages you start with a tag
in the middle of your documents you've
already got your HTML here
what it does is you start with a script
tag and then everything stops you've got
a closing script tag down here nothing
in this section will actually appear on
the users screen what you have here is a
completely separate programming language
you can declare variables you can do
calculations that's vaguely sensible you
can create an entire language in there
and that language can affect the
document so you can take the output from
that and you can put it into the rest of
the text so if you have for example an
email client Gmail uses this Gmail uses
incredible amounts of this because when
you type in things it it sends it to the
server so you don't have to send say
you've like in the early days the web
and then it would take a second to go
there in a second to come back just
quietly does it all in the background
it's really really powerful um it's the
way that everything big everything
interactive works on the web now you can
design entire games in JavaScript and
all it's doing is creating a web page
and then just moving bits about the
trouble is that javascript is dangerous
um it can do anything to the web page
and rightly so that's how Gmail works
but imagine if you could get whatever
JavaScript you wanted to do anything
would say are the login page of an
online bank you could tap it that
instead of just taking the username and
password and sending them to the bank
servers first it should send them to
someone else and when they've got them
and the user won't know that's happened
then it should log people into the back
ah
or you could say instead of you know
sending the words people are actually
typing to the web I ignore them just
send rick astley instead this is how
myspace worms spread because you would
type in the code and it would appear
because myspace hadn't quite felt in
JavaScript properly and that's the
cross-site scripting the bug I'll get to
in a minute
you could write anything you wanted in
there and every time someone looked at
that MySpace page the code would run and
it would say hey go do stuff with their
profile instead and it would javascript
is dangerous because it lets you do
anything on a web page so how do you
edit in that let's go to
a google here's Google here's a search
bar whatever I type in that search bar
test will probably appear on the next
page here test and it also appear here a
couple of times and here whatever I type
in here appears on this webpage that's
fine what happens if instead I type in
an italic tag
well what won't happen is that Google
will send the whole page in italics they
will do that because what they have done
is they have converted it into this less
than which is great let's imagine that
instead of typing test or instead of
typing that instead I type in script and
then some code as long as I write valid
code there and as long as the box is big
enough there's a few other hacks you can
do to make that work if as a web
developer you forget to do that little
trick that changes them from less than
signs for that code that means put a
less on sign in there your web server
puts the page out and the web browser
looks that and goes that is JavaScript
code I'm gonna run that and it does and
you can use that for our entertainment
uh I have previously used that at least
one place I shouldn't and of course the
doesn't do any damage doesn't only
lasting damage that all it does is in
that case change load of the words in
their website it's only visible to the
one person I've sent it to which is you
know not technically entirely legal
under the computer misuse Act but no one
press charges all I'm doing there is
playing about but the more sinister
stuff you can do with JavaScript quietly
stealing passwords and user information
letting you log in as other people all
of these things are entirely possible by
just letting unescape JavaScript get
into your webpage and here's the thing
is that here's the really important
thing all you need to do is mess up once
anywhere on your site with any user
input something that you think is
completely innocuous because someone is
just typing in their image if you forget
to escape that and someone types in a
little bit
so instead well congratulations your
website is now completely vulnerable and
this has happened regularly in Google in
Facebook in every single vid site
because it's so easy to forget um even
when every single framework out that
every single tool to help web developers
how some that goes guys you've missed
this you miss this you really need to do
that are you sure you really mean to do
that
you can still mess it up even the big
guys mess this up and they have what are
known as bug bounties they will pay you
money if you find something like this
and then responsibly tell them you don't
go and tell the world if you can do that
I think someone earned something like
twelve thousand dollars for finding a
bug in Facebook that let people do this
so rather than try and break things try
and mend them try and find something
like this is if this is your thing if
this is your something that you look at
and go oh I can try and break things
with this do it and then look at the big
guys and try on some money with it
instead cuz they will thank you they
will put your name in lights on your
site on their site and they will pay you
money because the alternative is the bad
guys getting this and the next time you
log into Google your password not going
where it's supposed to
we'd like to thank audible.com for their
support of this video and if you'd like
to download one of their vast range of
audiobooks you can go to audible.com
slash computer file and get one for free
we always like to recommend a book that
you could use for your freebie and I
asked sure one who makes our videos what
he'd like to recommend and today he's
gone for flat earth news by Nick Davies
which is an excellent book well worth a
listen so audible.com slash
computerphile check it out
get your free book and thank you so much
to them for their support of our films